so the first example is very very gentle
why don't you open up to one exercise 1a
and the first thing you look at is the
most simple kind of boring you can do
which is what they call all baby
sleeping it's what they call a flat rate
loan flat rate
now think back to FM to think back to FM
- when you hear the words flat great
what does that trigger in your mind
what's that this is straight line okay
you were to graph this the kind of
interests the kind of interest that
you're going to have to pay back right
because it's a straight line it's not
compounding it's it's closer we got a
Sussman s simply just very good okay so
when you see that you should think a
simple interest now simple interest I
think is literally the first formula on
your formula data sheet yeah but you let
this back in midnight Italian what's the
gloomy on the simple teachers okay good
so it's not complicated let me just
remind you how this works that's fine
that's fine I'm not gonna rub up any of
this as it example okay I will start off
as gently as possible right what is the
interest payable and just know that
little were clear payable signals to you
yeah it's the same idea as if someone
moves on as if you would let me someone
else money but the fact that it's
payable indicates you oh yeah actually I
earned this back to them okay so that's
the that indicates the direction the
money's going okay sorry
what's the interest payable on and so if
you're being asked for the interest
payable you should expect to see in the
rest of the question the what's this
again the principle how much you are
borrowing the rate at which you are
borrowing it and how long you have
borrowed it for okay so I've got some
months ago
how about
okay so this is nice and simple
it requires an unmodified use of this I
equals prt
formula so the first thing we do is I'm
going to say I equals alright what would
that be the right okay I can just quit
so my next thing is I've got to be able
to demonstrate I can substitute into
this formula right so my principle is
the 5000 my rate okay so I have a choice
here I can either 16.7% or I don't
encourage you to do this for reasons
I'll explain in a second
I owe you to convert that into a decimal
0.06 67 and then I'm going to multiply
my fault now quick question to you guys
why do you think I'm encouraging you to
convert this to a decimal on the fly any
suggestions I can think at least two
reasons
okay very good sir it actually helps you
get better at converting this to a
decimal right that's a fee plus a second
reason is I phrased this question so you
had to find out what the interest was
this would be some dollar amount okay
but you can see I could just as easily
have phrased the question like this tell
you how much interest you paid tell you
how much the principal was and how long
you had it and then ask you hey what's
the interest rate like what percentage
was it now your calculators not going to
hand back to you some number with the
percentage it's always going to hand out
to you a decimal so you can't avoid this
even though the decimal buttons sorry
the percentage button is nice you need
to be able read into it so you might as
well get in it there's some about a
number for me
1,000 wonderful that's it okay the would
point out just says we've seen in the
quiz that you just did when you have a
look at this question apart from the
obvious things like say their numbers
what might you underline what do you
think is that crucial information in
this question now it's time period that
where the time periods tapped into their
years is pretty obviously a time period
and then power out of them okay yeah
you've got to watch for these I gave you
a simple example to study where they
happen to match together but they might
not match right let's just change this a
little bit let's take the same question
but instead of saying for years let's
suppose it said 300 days hmm what am I
gonna have to do here it's different
yeah it's pretty much the same color but
instead of times going sometimes 360
okay so I've got the same principle
right the rate it sorry it hasn't
changed but the amount of time has
changed and it's not a whole nice number
right so 300 days is 300 over 365 of a
year right does that make sense
obviously if it's 365 then it'd be
exactly what you but it's a nice awkward
number for us anything you say okay sure
whatever that not that happens okay are
there any questions
we're always going to give you two
things number one we'll give you
information if we want you to do
something specific okay
assume that a year is three or sixty
five point two five they'll say that if
they want something lucky but otherwise
just like with the radar chopping look
that oh yeah they will actually give you
a pressure limitless sense answers so
long as you tell me
khloe's you tell me if you actually um
it's good right you've got good good
somebody actually find out what 305 is
like as a decimal yeah oh okay so you've
I'm sorry 275 oh yeah yeah actually
didn't I take about give me two more
okay now think about this right if
thinking this is a pretty easy question
you went straight here but then you use
some other number like 365 into five or
three six and six because it's 2016 this
year or something like that okay if you
go straight here the fact that you did
that that you chose a different number
is kind of disguised from your working
right because the worker is not there in
the same way if you went straight to
this number
it's like that number come from like did
you were you able to accurately
represent that it was this several days
out of a year whereas this I think makes
it completely unambiguous what you did
and if I wrote 365.25 there it's obvious
that I understand I've demonstrated the
process so this is just speaking to why
you should be working even for a one
might question there's something that
I've noticed over last few years this
would be one life pretty simple because
it's calculator work right but that
Lyons in point it's useful for us useful
for models okay